guys next segment of what's popping I
almost said smegma that's
shmegma is the dirty in people's
dick oh that's what smegma is I learned
that sad I still don't know what you're
referring to but it sounds don't wash
their body and there's like a
film of like dirt fungus in the layer of
your dick is called
so specific
it has its own word it must be happening
Miss Adams unless you're a bad teacher
Miss Adams and I said that wrong then
I'm just playing with you that's one of
the only things I learned in your class
okay out of here because I thought
it was funny I go there's a word for
something like that and I always used to
tell people I guess smegma on your lips
what yes
I was 18 saying the stupid
like a dumbass next next uh part of
what's popping makes perfect sense Dave
Chappelle's canceled question mark dot
dot dot dot okay so let's get
into this I didn't even put